Revenge might be a dish best served cold,
but these films all delivered red-hot justice.
Whether it was an entire film's worth of elaborate
plotting and execution or a single moment
of sweet revenge, here are some of the greatest
acts of revenge in movies ever.
The Gift
Joel Edgerton made his big-screen directorial
debut with 2015's The Gift, where he plays
Gordo, a seemingly sad sack who runs into
an old high school acquaintance named Simon,
played by Jason Bateman.
Gordo turns into something of an unwanted
shadow for the man and his wife Robyn, but
eventually, Gordo's kookiness becomes more
worrisome than weird.
As Simon’s secrets come to light, Gordo
steps up his psyche-unraveling campaign of
terror, including sending Simon disturbing
footage of his wife being drugged by Gordo
nine months before the birth of her baby.
In retaliation for a casual act of cruelty
that caused Gordo unfathomable pain, he makes
Simon's question whether or not his child
is actually even his.
Now that's what you call a mind game.
The Help
The Help from 2011 is set in the middle of
Mississippi during the civil rights movement.
Octavia Spencer plays Minny, the long-suffering
maid to the horrible Hilly, a self-declared
moral authority who leads the community charge
to segregate in-home bathrooms.
Minny is fired for using the guest restroom
rather than brave a storm to access the outhouse
facilities, but she makes Hilly eat her words
by cooking her a chocolate pie that contains
a new special ingredient.
Minny's...well...poop.
It sounds foul, but it's actually quite a
delicious moment to watch as Hilly's brain
catches up with her ears and understands what
she's just been told about the dessert she's
still ravenously chowing down.
Inglourious Basterds
Vigilante justice is an essential element
in many of Quentin Tarantino's movies, but
Inglourious Basterds tops Tarantino's catalogue
of excellent revenge moments.
It’s a blood-soaked take on World War II-styled
vengeance against some of history's most reprehensible
villains.
From Shosanna's orchestrated torching of the
Führer…
"Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
Ha"
...to Donny "Bear Jew" Donowitz's merciless
beatdown of an remorseless SS officer, to
Lt. Aldo Raine carving a swastika into Hans
Landa's forehead, Basterds dispenses justice
in ways that only make the intense violence
that much more entertaining.
Wanted
It’s a scene that makes Jerry Maguire's
office exit speech seem like a note with a
smiley face left on the company fridge.
In Wanted, Wesley politely announces his departure
from the corporate world…
"Some loser gets his head blown off at the
Metropolitan."
"SHUT THE F*%K UP!"
...and heads for the exit with his ripped-out
computer keyboard in hand.
His buddy and co-worker Barry, who's befuddled
by what Wesley's just said to their boss,
goes for the high five and gets a QWERTY to
the face instead.
Appropriate, since Barry had been sleeping
with Wesley’s girlfriend.
Wesley doubles down in his vengeance by making
out with the badass beauty Fox, played by
Angelina Jolie, right in front of her.
Man on Fire
In the 2004 action-drama Man on Fire, a retired
CIA operative named John Creasy, played by
Denzel Washington, takes a gig as the bodyguard-slash-babysitter
of a nine-year-old girl named Pita, but comes
to find that the job entails a lot more than
mere child's play.
When Pita is kidnapped, Creasy gets to work
finding and systematically slaughtering her
captors.
In the movie’s most memorable revenge scene,
Creasy ties a potential kidnapper down to
a car and, well…
"C4, highly explosive.
You put them all together and you got a bomb.
Not very sophisticated but very powerful.
That's what you have in your ass right now."
The perp spills the beans, but Creasy is unforgiving.
Never mess with Denzel.
Road to Perdition
This Depression-era drama, Road to Perdition,
follows Mafia enforcer Michael Sullivan, played
by Tom Hanks, seeking justice for his wife
and child, who were murdered by his mentor’s
son, Connor, played by Daniel Craig.
With his surviving son in tow, Sullivan works
his way through the deadly crime syndicate
to find Connor and make him pay.
The journey is filled with treachery and devastation,
but in the end, the parties who deserve it
get theirs—even Sullivan, whose son watches
him pay the ultimate sacrifice for his life
of violence.
The Shawshank Redemption
When the word “redemption” is in the title,
you can probably be sure that things will
turn around by the end of the movie, and the
40-year saga of Andy Dufresne's false imprisonment
is no exception.
While the man who actually committed the murders
for which Andy is convicted is eventually
imprisoned, he isn't the one who earns Andy's
true wrath.
Instead, it’s Shawshank’s Warden Norton,
who has the opportunity to free Andy after
evidence of his wrongful imprisonment comes
to light.
Instead of doing so, Norton punishes Andy
further—all the while, relying on Andy to
cook his books so he can launder money under
the name “Randall Stephens”.
After Andy escapes to freedom, he adopts the
Randall Stephens alias to siphon off the warden’s
ill-gotten loot, and turns evidence of Norton's
crimes over to the feds, leaving the warden
no choice but to off himself in his own office.
John Wick
A grieving widower receives a strange present
one day: an adorable little puppy, the final
gift from his dead wife, and a chance for
him to start over and appreciate life despite
his loss.
That's how 2014's John Wick, starring Keanu
Reeves starts out.
It doesn't take long, however, for the son
of a Russian mob boss to break into Wick's
house, kill his puppy, and beat him to a pulp
— all so he can steal his car.
Big mistake.
"Cause he stole John Wicks car sir, and ah,
killed his dog."
"oh"
That's when the viewers find out who John
Wick really is: one of the most fearsome and
effective hitmen to ever retire from the business.
"People keep asking if I'm back and I haven't
really had an answer.
But now, yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
What follows is one of the best, most action-packed
revenge movies in recent history, featuring
Wick taking out the Russian mob piece by piece.
When Wick finally catches up to the creep
who killed his dog, he takes out his bodyguards
with a sniper rifle, blows up his getaway
cars, and shoots him in the guts, all before
finally putting a bullet in his head while
he's mid-sentence.
"это был просто"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
revenge scenes are your favorite...